hallo mein darum ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen wie
die wir wahrscheinlich schon unschwer
erkennen können bin ich heute nicht
alleine sondern mit max kidd schon im
titel steht gerade versuche nicht
wegzuschauen das ist quasi eine trainer
typ wünscht challenge dies in amerika
england auch gibt und die haben auch
schon sehr viele youtube gemacht ich
würde allerdings sagen dass sie noch
niemand so krass gemacht hat wie wir das
heute tun also ohne spaß man muss
wirklich sagen ich weiß nicht wie viel
du zensieren müssen wird wenn ihr zart
besaitet zeit
man guckt dass auf jeden fall nicht
alleine da brechen sich leute hände dann
brechen sich leute füße also wirklich
wenn ihr gewalt nicht sehen können da
schaut das video so oder schaltet jetzt
wirklich ab wir sagen wir fangen jetzt
an
wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal auf play
ihr seht schon da sitzt ein typ dass er
mag sich tatsächlich schon gesehen und
mich so zusammenreißen wir haben wir
schon gesehen warum machen die das
überhaupt warum machen die das machen
dass leute ich bin da zurückgelaufen und
bin gegen das skateboard gelaufen luca
ging was bist du gerade gelaufen ging
jetzt geld gucken
[Musik]
oder doch vom 1
nein ich rede ich weiß wie das
herausgegeben gar nicht weiß wie das
ausgehen
ich seh leute bisher hatten alle sachen
brüche in sich also der erste sich die
hand gebrochen das zweite den fuß und
der dritte irgendwie also das kann man
sich nicht anschauen
der typ mit den fetten muskel wird jetzt
mit den kleinen seinen arm brechen ich
will da nicht hin stand ich werde auch
nicht hinschauen willst du hin schauen
ich wir können jetzt wir machen jetzt
weiter ich guckt nicht hin da war ich
zwar nicht schön ist das habe ich schon
gesehen das habe ich schon gesehen ja
das finde ich aber auch nicht so schlimm
war dass keine wiederholung glaube ich
wir haben mit auto herum warum alters
wieder warum macht man sowas warum das
fand ich habe mir vor dem schrank geholt
haben
der erst das ist einfach so etwas gar
nicht dass das juckt nicht wirklich auch
also auch durch wir müssen jetzt mal
wirklich hat die ganzen hinschauen
scheiße hatte das sind 3 ssds wecken
nein
hey warum junge hörer auf er blutet
einfach direkt was bringt es was hat das
für einen sinn mein gesicht rhein bis
zum comeback gestört ich wusste ja
hinguckt das ist ja die challenge nicht
wegzuschauen aber jetzt den fuß
gebrochen
bitterfeld nach in seinen fuß nein nein
nein ein alter da kannst du dir auch mal
so schnell das geht nicht bei brechen
das geht so schnell die einfach das
genick dabei zu brechen heute macht es
nicht den rosen fällt ihnen einfach um
warum also was ist so schlimm wenn die
leute so kopfüber ins gesicht fallen hat
er erliegt dem feuer ich hab immer so
angst hat den skateplatz gegen die wir
so schlecht dabei was vor allem wenn
quad auf nicht drauf fällt
weiter hält rasche channel jahreshoch ok
ich ja das ist aber der schock mit der
demokratie gebrochen hatte
warum so schlimm ich habe nicht richtig
sagt zweitweise fuß und umgedreht marx
hat gerade weggeschaut hat er muss sich
das nochmal anschauen
nein ich habe nichts unterschrieben hat
den kopf auf das video direkt bei
youtube
ich kann kein empty versucht die ganze
familie mir das auch ich bin immer raus
ich sehe nicht mehr was dann auf dem
bildschirm ist leute die immer nur was
mit den eiern
[Applaus]
alter schwede der sck 45 meter einfach
von seinem bike weg und ist so nach
vorne gesprungen dann voll mit dem
gesicht auf dem boden leute wir schauen
das video jetzt natürlich auch noch
zusammen zu ähnlich meinte es geht noch
eine minute aber ich habe ja zu beginn
gesagt dass ich das ganze nicht
zensieren werde ich glaube das muss ich
allerdings doch machen einfach damit das
ganze so ein bisschen vielleicht nicht
komplett ab 21 freigegeben wird
ok hat sich in die fresse geschlagen
aber das habe ich nicht so genau gesehen
ok wieder das war schon okay ich hab
noch hingeschaut ich habe noch
hingeschaut roosters wieder ich habe den
fuß gesehen mehr passen auto das nicht
wirklich okay das ist
so wenn leute sich bewusst wählt einfach
dumm sind dann habe ich ein geringes
problem also wenn leute einfach so beim
sport umknicken das war ohne spaß
die härteste change die ich je gemacht
habe also ich hab sie ja verpackt aber
das ist wirklich die härtesten stellen
wir haben sie beide ca 10 15 mal
verkauft muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn
jedes video so gewesen wäre wie das
erste oder das zweite wohl wirklich nach
aufnahmen gesehen dass wir gegen wieder
hand bericht oder irgendwie sowas habe
ich ja dann letztendlich auch zensiert
aber wenn alles so gewesen wäre
ich höre dass das war viel zu krank
gewesen ist echt zum fluss magen gefühl
nach diesem video mein herz rast ein
bisschen muss dann ich habe so ein
bisschen haben ein bisschen adrenalin
zustand wenn euch das video gefallen hat
der last gerne mal leichter wie gesagt
max und ich wollte einfach mal dieser
challenge stellen wir haben beide
glorreich versagt ihr findet jetzt hier
ein smiley eingeleitet werde darauf
könnte meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren
verpasst keine videos mehr da oben
findet auch meinen shop eingeblendet und
hier unten ist ein anderes video
verlinkt also check derart also ich
glaube dass es gut sein